i don't think you can say that
women are more emotional than women i
mean the men sorry i would say that we
have like we i think we said earlier
that we both
process and show it differently
and so i say our emotional intelligence
are basically the same it's just the way
that we show it in the way that we
express or react to it is very very
different
because things that hurt us will hurt us
but the way that you react to it is a
hundred percent different
so oh go ahead bro but
sorry i'm so afraid
no no no no so so but you don't think
like we have different hormones than men
do so like emotionally like we're a
different person every single day
because because like it depends where we
are in our cycle you already know you
already know a couple days before our
period comes
don't mess with me
would your ex-boyfriend say the same
they would they would they would attest
hang on let me just try and clarify this
are you saying that as a woman
you are acknowledging
that
when you're coming your period you are
differently emotionally the days before
yeah
oh my gosh hormonally yeah you literally
are
yeah i'll cry and i'm like why am i
crying all right all right so
if a man was to say
right so you've already acknowledged it
right so if so if a man wants to say
you know what you're coming your period
you're probably a little bit emotional
how would you respond to that well first
of all
when you say that obviously that would
piss the woman off yeah but hang on hang
on but hang on it doesn't make any sense
because you've already acknowledged it
well yes you already know you've
acknowledged the fact that you are
different when you're coming in your
period
but hang on when a man acknowledges it
and says to you uh you know what you're
coming period a little bit why is it why
is it going to piss you off because he's
telling the truth i think because you're
asking this question you already kind of
know the answer i mean
come on
i'm just saying why get pissed off when
you know fred used to do that to me i
agree with what he's saying so i feel
like it's also sort of how a man says it
like in what context that conversation
is in but it's true like if he's saying
like he acknowledges it say you were
also ignored as a woman like i go
through these like pre-menstrual uh mood
swings or post mentals or even during
when
your menstrual cycle
like why is it crazy if the man says it
to you as a as ammo not even ammo not
ammo it's just an
like as i think because
it kind of diminished i feel it is it
patronizing it makes them feel like
you're diminishing what they feel when
you think so it's a feelings thing yes
right so that's what and that's the
thing you like men don't men process
information differently from women right
and so a man will be very logical with
his with his uh conclusion they'll be
like oh you know what this woman is
acting this way because okay maybe she's
coming on the period right okay cool
this woman's acting this way because
she's common appeared and i'm just going
to say it listen babe you're acting
you're not acting right because you're
coming your period but hang on
you you as a woman yeah
are saying
that's gonna piss me off
but it's in the truth
we can't handle the chances
and this has happened to you how many
times
wait wait wait multiple times multiple
times now right and so if it's happened
to you once then why wouldn't it get
through your thick [ __ ] skull that
would happen the next time no because
what i'm trying to do is i'm trying to
make you understand that you're being
irrational right now irrational yeah
you're being irrational because i'm
telling you the truth
and you can't handle it right if i tell
you the sky is blue and you go crazy
because the sky's blue now i'm gonna be
like what the hell is wrong with you
like just calm the [ __ ] down right what
it doesn't make sense just like i'm
telling you this guy's blue it's it's a
tree it's a fact like why are you so
crazy about a fact i don't i don't get
it i don't get it so you're saying that
um
because i have brothers group around
boys so i i understand not fully how
they process because
but
so if someone comes to you saying
something correct and you get hurt like
if i say hey like you have a hair
sticking up like you need to like do
something with that and you were like
well why is she coming to me saying that
is that something that the man needs to
check or you need to check how you
accept how they're saying
and i'm not saying i'm not saying just
you i'm just saying just i'm here for
this conversation
whenever someone comes to you and
they're
there
and they're just
you know and
people say something to you and they
don't mean it that way but you take it
that way is that something you need to
analyze yourself okay why why did i take
that that way or yeah do i talk to them
and be like hey
did you say it this way okay
accountability is a thing
right maybe it's the tone
no but the thing is but and that's the
thing that sometimes men
like a man will generally men will
generally speak straightforward which i
mean we're not i would say so yeah we're
not talking about that we're not
wondering
we're not worrying about what type of
time of the month it is for you
we'll you say hey listen this is a cup
but i would say what do you mean it's a
cup
yo yo
it's a [ __ ] cup okay
but i feel like women take things so
different like you know like even as a
female i could go up to another female
like say i'm not really friends with him
like you know what your hair's sticking
up here well i think ego is such a big
thing for a female yeah oh yeah i think
people always put ego on men no honey
it's females as well and i feel like
they're like what do you mean like
they're just straight on smoke and it's
like you're not i think why are you on
sleep i'm actually trying to help you
i've said women don't like women
generally yeah i agree like exactly
women and it depends on the country like
other women because
because women are women's competition
and so
if you if i said if you were to bring
another three women in here yeah right
the women will be like analyzing these
women like you know [ __ ] these guys
you know what i'm saying like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right so women generally don't like
women did that happen when i came later
when men men's competition for another
man is different from a woman's country
because a man will a man will look at a
man's
success
when we look at men as a man we look at
them defined successfully all right so
you look at jay-z or puff daddy or
warren buffett or let's bring it out to
your level a man a man will look at
another man's success and maybe be
envious of his success yeah we don't
generally i'm not saying it doesn't
happen we don't generally look at other
men and be like look he's looking look
at what he's wearing i don't think
you're what's he wearing why is he
wearing that
i'm saying generally i'm saying okay
generally like i'm not saying men don't
do it but men don't look at other men
and think oh my god look at his hair
what okay look at his boots women do
that women look at other women's shoes
and get jealous of that [ __ ] and start
doing it i can i can i don't care
like you said generally yeah generally
there are some that don't but
i've i've experienced some men that do
and but it's not the
vast majority but i do agree with you
that
i